Creo que hay una cosa en la que todos vamos
a estar de acuerdo:
Internet ha cambiado nuestra forma
de vida.
Tanto que según las estadísticas el 65%
de los españoles o casi 3 de cada 4 estadounidenses
no pueden imaginarse ya la vida sin Internet.
Servicios de música, de noticias, de compras
y sobre todo de vídeo… como por ejemplo,
esta plataforma, YouTube … todo este ingente
volumen de datos, amigos, no hace más que
crecer y crecer.
Y, ojo, según las estimaciones de Cisco tan
sólo en los próximos 5 años, Estados Unidos
multiplicará por 3 su tráfico de Internet.
De hecho en 2015 Estados Unidos alcanzó y
pasó a Corea del Sur convirtiéndose en el
líder mundial en “consumo” per cápita
de datos.
Y por supuesto, internet, este gran mundo
virtual, cada vez está más integrado en
la vida de todos nosotros y supone una mayor
parte de la actividad económica.
Así que, con todo esto, ya os podéis imaginar
dos cosas:
la primera, la enorme cantidad de infraestructuras
que todo este consumo demanda, y la segunda,
lo importante que resulta la propia regulación
de Internet.
Pues bien, el pasado 14 de diciembre de 2017,
la Comisión Federal de Comunicaciones de
Estados Unidos tomó una decisión que creo
bien podemos calificar de histórica, por
su transcendencia y, sobre todo, por su controversia:
Amigos, como seguro sabéis, esta Comisión
Federal de las Comunicaciones decidió, por
3 votos contra 2, poner punto y final a la
llamada “neutralidad de la red”.
Una regulación que fue aprobada en 2015 a
petición del propio presidente Obama.
En poco tiempo Twitter, los medios de comunicación
y practicamente cualquier espacio de debate
vio difundirse un mensaje:
estamos ante el final de Internet tal y como
lo conocemos.
[Por cierto, este hombre es Ajit Pai, el presidente
de la Comisión Federal de las Comunicaciones
y el gran protagonista de toda esta historia.
Y probablemente, una de las personas más
odiadas de Internet.]
Pues bien, creo que hay un par de preguntas
que tenemos que contestar:
¿En qué consistía fundamentalmente esta
regulación? ¿Qué supone realmente este
cambio?
Mirad, básicamente en 2015 se decidió que
Internet pasara de estar regulado por el Título
primero de la ley de Comunicaciones, a estarlo
por el titulo segundo.
Pero, ¿Qué diantres significa esto?
(Pues para que nos entendamos, podemos decir
que con este cambio, Internet - la provisión
del servicio - pasaba a ser considerado como
un servicio público y a estar fuertemente
regulado por el gobierno, en este caso por
la Comisión de Federal de las Comunicaciones.)
Una regulación que entre otras cosas impedía,
que las operadoras, como por ejemplo Comcast,
Verizon o AT&T pudieran, por un lado, bloquear
o ralentizar a su antojo el tráfico de ciertos
espacios web o aplicaciones; y por otro lado,
impedir que dieran preferencia a otros proveedores
de contenido.
Imaginaos el caso de una compañía que decide
dar preferencia a Netflix por encima de HBO,
o también por ejemplo, a una compañía que
le diga a Spotify que va a tener que pagar
si quiere que sus clientes puedan hacer uso
de sus servicios de música en streaming a
alta velocidad.
(Con esta regulación, las compañías, tampoco
podían cobrar cuotas que no incluyesen el
acceso a algún servicio. Imaginemos, por
ejemplo, una empresa que quiera una conexión
de alta velocidad pero que no consuma vídeos
de Netflix, Prime Video o HBO. No importa,
con esta regulación tenía que pagar por
el servicio completo. Las compañías no podían
ofrecerle una tarifa sin Netflix.”)
Sin embargo, amigos, ahora todo esto se ha
terminado. En Estados Unidos las compañías
ahora pueden determinar libremente sus tarifas,
por ejemplo ofreciendo una tarifa de acceso
a internet que no incluya el poder vídeos
en 4K.
Ojo, no quiere decir que lo vayan a hacer,
pero probablemente sí que veamos aparecer
tarifas muy diferentes.
Pues bien, esto es lo que hizo que las redes
se incendiaran con esta polémica decisión.
Tan polémica que tan solo 107 de los 239
congresistas republicanos en la Cámara de
Representantes, han hecho público su apoyo
a esta decisión.
Pero… ¿Pensáis que todo esto es tan malo?
¿Creéis que Internet ya no será lo mismo?
Pues… esperad un momento.
¿UNA AMENAZA CONTRA INTERNET?
En primer lugar veamos las sombras, los motivos
por los que los defensores de la neutralidad
en la red consideran que este cambio es tan
negativo.
Creo que estos puntos son, con diferencia,
los más conocidos así que tampoco nos vamos
a detener mucho.
Los detractores del cambio impulsado por el
partido republicano sustentan sus posiciones
en 2 argumentos clave:
Primero, que como las operadoras ahora podrán
cobrar extras tanto a las empresas como a
los clientes, el coste de internet va subir
y muchas pequeñas empresas y start ups no
van a poder competir con las más grandes,
porque no van a poder pagar por un acceso
preferente.
Segundo, porque supone el fin de la libertad
sobre la que se construyó internet. Imaginemos
que una operadora decide reducir la velocidad
o, incluso bloquear, el acceso a un medio
de comunicación. Teóricamente es algo que
podría ocurrir.
(“Nuestra economía de Internet es la envidia
del mundo porque está abierta a todos. Esta
propuesta es un ataque a esa apertura. Da
a los proveedores de banda ancha el poder
de decidir qué voces amplificar, qué sitios
podemos visitar, qué conexiones podemos establecer
y qué comunidades crear. Disminuye el acceso,
frena las oportunidades y censura el contenido.”
Jessica Rosenworcel, miembro demócrata en
la Comisión Federal de Comunicaciones.)
Bueno, todo esto es bien conocido, son los
argumentos que básicamente se han utilizado
en la mayoría de los medios de comunicación.
Sin embargo, amigos, ya sabéis que en VisualPolitik
nos gusta buscar un poquito más allá, así
que, vamos a ello.
LAS LUCES TAMBIÉN CUENTAN
Los partidarios de acabar con la llamada “neutralidad
en la red” lo tienen claro: un mercado con
mucha competencia es la mejor garantía para
impulsar la innovación y garantizar un buen
servicio al cliente.
Y una cosa, amigos, es cierta: Internet surgió,
creció y se desarrolló fundamentalmente
como un espacio libre sin que existiese esa
regulación que conocemos como “neutralidad
en la red”.
Fijaos en las palabras, de Marc Andreessen,
cofundador de Netscape y personaje clave en
el nacimiento de Facebook:
(“Una visión de una neutralidad pura en
la red es difícil de sostener si también
quieres tener una inversión continua en redes
de banda ancha. (…) Si existieran estas
normas de neutralidad pura en la red por las
que no se podría cobrar nunca nada a una
empresa como Netflix, no vas a conseguir nunca
obtener un retorno sobre una inversión continua
en la red, lo que significa que dejarás de
invertir en la red. Y yo no quiero estar durante
los próximos 10 o 20 años con las mismas
velocidades de ancho de banda que tenemos
hoy”. Marc Andreessen.)
Sí, este uno de los principales criticas
que ha motivado el cambio: la regulación
desincentiva a las empresas a invertir. Algo
que parece claro con las estadísticas en
la mano.
Fijaos, como hemos visto antes, en los últimos
años el tráfico de internet en Estados Unidos
ha crecido muchísimo… sin embargo, sorprendentemente,
la inversión en infraestructura de banda
ancha se ha estancado e incluso reducido en
los últimos años.
Algo que evidentemente no es normal y, que
por ejemplo, alimenta uno de los grandes problemas
que el sector tiene en Estados Unidos: la
falta de competencia en muchas partes del
país.
Pero claro, si la regulación dificulta y
reduce la rentabilidad potencial del negocio…
los incentivos a invertir también se reducen
sustancialmente. Lógico ¿no os parece?
Otro punto que alegan los partidarios de acabar
con la regulación de Obama, es que esta era
una regulación que no solo perjudicaba la
inversión sino que además era completamente
innecesaria.
(“Durante casi veinte años, Internet prosperó
bajo el enfoque de una regulación ligera
establecido por el presidente Clinton y un
Congreso republicano. Este marco bipartidista
llevó al sector privado a invertir $ 1.5
trillones en la construcción de redes de
comunicaciones en todo Estados Unidos. Y nos
dio una economía de Internet que se convirtió
en la envidia del mundo” Ajit Pai.)
Según alegan estos partidarios, en los 20
anteriores a la “neutralidad de la red”
esto es entre 1995 y 2015, el acceso a Internet
no hizo más que extenderse y mejorar en velocidad
y calidad.
Durante este tiempo surgieron las grandes
empresas digitales que hoy conocemos como
Google, Facebook, Netflix o Uber por poner
solo algunos ejemplos.
De hecho, es curioso, pero las operadoras
no han sido las grandes ganadoras del nacimiento
de Internet.
Fijaos, tan sólo Alphabet, esto es Google,
tiene una capitalización, un valor en bolsa
que es bastante mayor que el valor conjunto
de las tres mayores operadores de telecomunicaciones
de Estados Unidos.
Así que, ¿por qué cambiar algo que ha funcionado
tan bien desde su nacimiento? Se preguntan.
¿Cuando una operadora ha restringido el acceso
a un medio de comunicación o a Gmail?
(De hecho, la única vez que ocurrió algo
parecido, cuando Comcast quiso bloquear las
conexiones p2p para frenar las descargar ilegales,
al final tuvo que dar marcha atrás, por la
mala publicidad y también por la presión
de las autoridades.)
Porque amigos, y este es el tercer punto,
menos regulación no implica anarquía.
De hecho, a partir de ahora, en Estados Unidos,
Internet pasará a estar regulado por la poderosa
Comisión Federal del Comercio, que es la
encargada de la política antimonopolio. Y,
además, las operadoras tendrán que cumplir
con una estricta política de transparencia.
Tendrán que comunicar claramente cualquier
política que restrinja o favorezca la velocidad
de acceso a cualquier servicio digital.
(La verdad es que el cielo no se va a caer.
La Comisión Federal del Comercio va a ser
una policía enérgica a la hora de patrullar,
como ya lo ha sido, en lo que respecta a los
proveedores de internet”. Jon Leibowitz,
presidente de la Comisión Federal de Comercio
bajo la Administración Obama
“The truth is the sky is not going to fall
down. The FTC is going to be a vigorous cop
on the beat, as it has been,” with respect
to internet providers”. Jon Leibowitz, a
former Obama-era FTC chairman.)
Los defensores de la reforma de hecho ponen
dos ejemplos de cómo el mercado puede evolucionar
sin la “neutralidad”.
Uno es el mercado de telefonía móvil mucho
más competitivo y que siempre ha jugado en
el límite de la legalidad.
(Aquí los usuarios han visto reducirse sus
tarifas al tiempo que mejoraba el servicio.
Hoy existen, por ejemplo, promociones que
incluyen el acceso ilimitado a servicios como
Netflix sin consumo de datos. Lo que, claramente,
viola el espíritu de la neutralidad en la
red.)
Bien, el segundo ejemplo que suelen poner,
lo encontramos, curiosamente, en los compañías
aéreas, particularmente en la compañía
JetBlue.
Veréis estas compañías no estaban sometidas
a la neutralidad en la red. Pues bien, a pesar
de ello, y de tener un acuerdo con Amazon
para priorizar el consumo de Prime Video a
bordo de sus aviones, decidió libremente
no castigar otros servicios, como HBO, por
ejemplo.
(“Nuestra estrategia para Wi-Fi en vuelo
es ofrecer el mejor servicio, al menor costo,
a tantos pasajeros como sea posible así que
estamos motivados para apoyar todo el contenido
de una manera justa y neutral." Mark Dankberg,
Director Ejecutivo de Viasat INC, compañía
satelital que proporciona el Internet de JetBlue.)
En fin amigos, estamos, sin duda, ante una
cuestión compleja, pero creo de verdad que
se han exagerado bastante las consecuencias,
y por supuesto no creo que estemos, ni mucho
menos ante el finde Internet.
Si alguna operadora se excede será, seguro,
castigada por el mercado.
Y sí, es verdad, en gran parte de Estados
Unidos hay un problema serio de competencia
porque no hay mercado para elegir operadora,
solo hay disponibles redes de una o dos compañías.
Pero me pregunto si lo que se necesita para
solucionar dicha situación ¿no es más inversión
y el desarrollo de nuevas tecnologías como
el 5G, por ejemplo?. Algo que por fortuna,
parece está a la vuelta del esquina.
En fin amigos, con este vídeo os hemos querido
mostrar las diferentes posiciones ante un
tema tan controvertido. Yo personalmente me
quedo con un deseo: que Internet siga siendo
lo más libre posible.
Pero ahora, turno para ti ¿Qué te parece
el final de la “neutralidad en la red”?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo dale
a like. ¡Un saludo, y gracias por estar ahí!